thank you very much Kiefer for accepting  that award and as you noticed today  Okajima is not here with us tonight I  want to tell you a little bit about that  mr. kijima had every intention of being  with us tonight but unfortunately he was  informed by a lawyer representing konami  just recently that he would not be  allowed to travel to tonight's awards  ceremony to accept any awards it's a  piece on an employment contract and it's  it's disappointing and it's it's  inconceivable to me that an artist like  gadea would not be allowed to come here  and celebrate with his peers and his  fellow teammates such an incredible game  as Metal Gear Solid 5 but that's the  situation we're in today 0 is in Tokyo  right now watching the show so we want  you to know who Dale that we're thinking  of you and we miss you we hope to see  you at the game awards 2016  you